me
こんにちは
ね皆さんの続中って聞いたことありますか
脳の血管が溢れたりそれから詰まったりして脳の中にある神経回路が壊れてしまうそう
いう病気ですあのええまあらいって言って病院に行くとまあこういうような写真が
撮れるんですけど
脳の中の様子を見てみるとこんな違いがあります左が結構
をな人なので右側がご存知の方の
のんです違いがわかりますか
右側の写真の真ん中らへんに白い影が映ってますよね
ここが脳卒中によってできた脳の木里なんです
あの僕がは高校生の時におじいちゃんが脳卒中になりました
すごいショックだったんですよねあのある日を境に突然
体の半分我慢してしまう
立つこともままならないから車いすで話すこともしないと
here それもまたすごく
[ __ ]で
で僕はそういうのを見てどうにかしてそういう脳卒中を治すようなそういうことでい
ないかなと思ったんですね
それで僕はもう療法学部に進みました
なんかちょっと変だなと思いませんが買って脳の病気のことをね
研究したに直したいと思ったら普通医学部に行くと思うんですよ
だけどまぁお恥ずかしい話僕はあの医学部に行くほど成績が良かったわけじゃないん
ですよね
あの4社から進んでいってまぁのんびり生活しだということもあってバリバリ勉強して
やつよねなかなか追いつかない
だけどまぁ僕はハイテクなことはしていなかったのでじゃあ人コーチの
それからロボットとこういうものを勉強して患者さんの役に立ちようなものを作りたい
な
そう思って理工学部
理工学部に行くとまぁ色んな事を勉強するんですプログラムを勉強したり筋肉の反応
計測するような電気回路を自分で設計してハンダ付けしてねそういう海を作ったりまあ
そんなことをしました
米子学部に行くと4年生になって研究室というのに入ります
研究すれば今まで勉強してきたことの実践の演習のばまずのような感じなんです
で僕は十派の念願の医学部と共同研究をたくさん当時一番していた研究者の一つに入る
ことができました
それですごくじ坊に萌えてあのどんな風にこういう技術が
以上の現場で使われてるんだろうなぁと思ってそれで慶応病院に行きました
でデイリーが許されたリハビリ科の部屋に入って
新昨日だとか訓練士だとかそういうのを覗かせてもらったんですね
だけどあの僕は結構あの
理工学部の中で科学技術が未来を変えるんだって散々後聴いて育ってきた
僕からするとちょっと意外な光景が広がってたんです
で食べればこの写真左側のものはプラスチックでできた手袋みたいなもんですね
これ遭遇って言います臨んチューナーとてがこわばって気が握りこんでしまうからこう
いう形 i 遭遇を使ってでがまっすぐになるように補正するんですね
それから右の写真俺は大きな文字でに
針金がループ状になっていて麻痺してなかなかうまく動かせないに誤字ない手を使って
でも洋服が着れるようにする前には顔 dart 女みたいなボタン同士みたいな道具
なんですね
bouvet 散々科学技術ロボットカー人コーチロス
の芽生えそういうセンター技術に囲まれて勉強してきた僕にとってやっぱり何も
もどかしいんですね
そういった快適な技術というのがその矢上キャンパスを超えて以上の現場にある白の街
に届いてないんだな
そういうのをリハビリを現場を見て思いました
そんなもどかしさを抱えながら僕は胃がんググッと
枚が来る鳥房楽のこのギャップを埋めるような研究を続けていってそれで博士が思って
おりました
理工学部の教員になって創出
教え子を育てていって0小さなグループがてき始めました
である時その仲間たちと一緒にいろんな話をごはん食べながらしているときにこんな
ことを思いついたんですね
体が動かないなら
乗ったらそのまま信号を読み取って
その人の考えていることを機械で読み出してそれでゲームの中のキャラクター
思い通りに操作するそんなようなへいパーシーのような技術を作ったらどうなんじゃ
ないか
でこのゲームはインターネットでつながっていて世界中のいろんな人がアクセスをして
ゲームの中で
会話をしたり三保したりする言葉
それからショッピングまできる
これはすごいこれぞはいてくだ
そんなふうに僕はワクワクしていろんな人にこんな愛ではどうですかという風に話をし
たんですね
だけど海底の場合この話を聞いた人はこんな反応しました
だいたいですね普通に生活している延長で捉えられないようなちょっと突飛な話を聞く
と人間体でこうやって笑い飛ばしちゃうんですね
あるいはこんなこと言ったって55を超えで難しくてそんなも役立たないよって言って
なんかこうイライラしながら反論する人もいました
だけど僕はあの諦めなくてあの
こういうことに向かって一緒に走ってくれる仲間を探しながら
学生と一緒にプログラムを変えデー
脳活動をリアルタイムにを分析して考えた通りにバーチャルリアリティの中のゲーム
キャラクターを操作するようにそういう技術を開発しました
シェールがれがですねあの
実際に筋ジストロフィーの33で首から下が麻痺してしまった三者さんが僕たちの技術
を使ってにもことで扱ってる様子ぞ
滞在したものですん
6の活動の読み取り精度はまだ悪くて飛び込み子供刺したのでこんな風に池ポチャし
ちゃうんですけどでもまあそれでも楽しみながらアン者さんは
インターネットの中のはジェリ相手のキャラクターを操作し生ピッチャーが3
キャンパス見る3法学部の学生と一緒に
会話をしながら散歩を楽しむですん
待ち合わせ場所
印税この映像を公開したときの反響はものすごいん
広く塾大学の広報室漁が始まって以来の反響だっていう風に言ってもらえる方のツバの
大きな反響をもらって
香りがは映像を通じて私達の右足は世界に保存される左ましたんですかーっ
に知ってこうした経験を前で僕たちが得た教訓というのは
たら新年はいいんだぜ
友達中何オンスともにドン前に進むんだ
ゲーム物を得る
笑われてもいいバカにされてもいいんだけど
は細く的に考えて
これが正しい道なんだって思った時には
間明フェスに言えばり族説明知って
それで仲間を探し俺
そういうことが必ず次の10先
開閉
あ悲しいミラーを作れればと実装のほうがいい
僕たちはつの脳の活動を読み取る技術を応用して
最初にお話した脳卒中によって生じてしまったマギーを治療する技術の開発にも
取り組みました
30の話たみたいに脳卒中って脳の血管が破れたり詰まったりして脳の中の神経回路の
一部が壊れてしまう
急い病気なんですけれども
左の角黄色で書かれているところのように脳の中にはまだ
巻付てる金リングにつながっている神経回路っていうのがまだ残ってるんですね
だからさっきの技術と同じように頭の上に電極を分かって
脳の中に残っている神経回路の活動ていうのを呼び出しますそれで患者さんが手を
動かそうとしたときに脳の中に残ってる神経回路の発動がグーッと上がってきたときに
ログウッドを駆動させて巻してるっての動きをアシストしてあげる
うそういう技術です
影さんはこうした機械の動作を通じて自分の中に残っている神経回路を自分で活動さ
せる
まあそういうことを学習していきます
第4 fl なるほどを1日一時間それから2週間から4週間くらい継続したときに脳
の中にどんな変化があるのかということを調べてみました
mri を使って脳の中の活動を見ているとあの日もうって書いてあるところの立つぞ
これを貸そうとしている時の脳の活動表してるんですけど最初は全然反応のなかったの
でも訓練を続けていくと右のスライドのように
の中の運動に関連している領域の活動が立った
に出てくるこういうことがわかってきました
マキシている実際のての開き具合も良くなってきたんですね
自分こういったデバイスを外した生身の体で自分の巻した手を使って物をつかんだり
話したりっていうのが再びできるようになりました
最近では僕らばーさらにあのこういった技術を応用して方のみ妖怪受講流動出場です
デバイスの開発の一斉5章じゃない
いやーこれ5さんがセンター
方を上げようとしている時に運動に関連したの活動を読み出して脳も活性化レベルが
ずーっと上がってきた缶ビールで初めてロボットフクロウさせて方もあり動きを
ロボットがサポートしますなる
阿部そうするとこの患者さんの場合は右のスライドのように彼が一番上まで上がるよう
になりました
なんですけどこれ1日1時間ほどの空ね
7日間くらいやった結果ですね
でこれからはロボットだけを使って治療した場合あるいは
方を上げるぞというイメージを繰り返ししただけの場合と比べて
こういった治療がどれくらい大きなほかほかんってことを詳細に調べていく段階に入り
ません
こういう風な脳の機能を再生させる
そういう再生医療デバイスの開発を首相を持ってドクターが相談した時もやっぱり最強
の話と同じように大笑いされたんですよね
マギーが非常に重くて脳卒中発症を6か月も過ぎてしまったケースの場合位
これまでのリハビリ医療の常識ではもうこれ以上治りませんっていうのがまあ普通だっ
たんですね
だけどもう1人目貼ってみてもなかな
2人目やってみたも何か良い反応が出てくるまぁそうやって結果を少しずつ少しずつ
積み上げていくとだんだんドクターやセラピストの目の色が変わってくるんですね
荒野なんかこれ本当に治るかもしれないなまあそんな風に変わってくるわけです
ブーブー経験をたくさんしたせいかアティロン here 女性になってしまいまし
でこの部屋はですね今僕が大学生の時に医学部のリハビリっカーンの中で使うして
もらっていた研究室なんですよね
四畳半の小さな部屋の中に検査し検査装置とパソコンが一台ずつ
これしかありません
で僕は医者でもないそれから有名な脳科学の研究室出身でもないんだけどこういう
小さな部屋が出発して今や脳の中
脳機能を再生させるそういうデバイスの開発に携わりながら世界中の研究者達と切磋
琢磨してこうやって研究することができている
そういうことができるようなんだろも先ほどの話と同じで同じ未来に向かって進んで
いく
仲間たちの存在なんですね
僕は今もこうして仲間達と一緒に楽しみながら研究をしています
だから皆さんもぜひこのみちゃん
こういうふうに信じた道を見つけて仲間たちと一緒に諦めずにいっぽいを積んでいく
まあそういうことを実践していってもらいたいなというふうに思います
今日はどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]